Hello,
everyone, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Happy New Year. I hope you all enjoyed
your vacation time off, family time, or whatever
you got up to over the last few
weeks.
My name is David Flanagan. I'm the host
here, and this is an episode of Rawkode
live. Rawkode live is a show where we
take a look at the latest and greatest
open source tools within the cloud native and
adjacent spaces.
And today, we are doing a bit of
a follow-up where we previously took a look
at Gitea,
an open source alternative to using GitHub, GitLab,
etcetera. And today, we're gonna see what's new
and take a look at Gitea
actions.
Same as last time, we're gonna be joined
by Matthew from the Gitea team. Hey, man.
How's it going? Hey. It's going well. Thanks.
So just a brief, rundown on me.
Not much has changed last time. I'm still
a project lead of Gitea. We
just celebrated
our, eighth year birthday,
just in no
sorry. We're going into our eighth year starting
in November, so I think it's seventh birthday,
how that works.
2016 was when we started.
Yeah.
So lots of exciting new developments with Gitea
since last time we chatted.
In 2022,
we launched
the alpha of
Giteactions,
the built in CICD solution. And
with this latest major release this past fall,
we
it's now
fully released, and everyone can use it. It's
compatible with GitHub actions, and I'm excited to
be here to talk with you about it
and walk through
getting it set up and using it.
Awesome.
Well, it's been about a year, and you've
covered most of the things that have changed,
which is cool. But, like, I'm curious about
you know, new features are amazing. Like, we
love open source and new features that get
involved and contributing. Right?
But you're now starting I've seen Gitea Cloud
is emerging. There's now the company coming up
behind it to support that open source contribution.
Maybe you wanna share a little bit a
bit more of that and how that's all
gone as well. Yeah. Definitely.
So Commico was
founded by some of the members of the
oversight committee and
as a way of being able to support
the project itself.
And so
we've been able to
in 2023
or sorry. In 2022, we were doing about
a hundred pull requests merged,
reviewed, etcetera, a month. And after the founding
of the company,
we went up to 400 a month. Woah.
And
so
lots of
refactoring to ensure it's stable, lots of new
features, lots of bug fixes,
lots of
a lot more
new maintainers,
community contributors.
We just hit 40,000
stars on GitHub.
And so
it's been very exciting, and Gitea Cloud is
a way of
letting people most familiar with Gitea being able
to run your instance for you and being
able to
support the project back through that.
So even, like, through
building it out, there's
features that we needed,
bug fixes that we've been able to
from dog booting your project, being able to
put it back in.
And so,
yeah, it's yeah.
All very exciting.
Yeah. I was actually
exploring a new home from, like, the Rawkode
Academy source, and, you know, I think Gitea
is pretty much where I'm gonna end up.
And one of the things that swayed me,
and it's so superficial and I feel ashamed
of myself. Right? But it wasn't like any
of the amazing features.
It was like the design
of the exclusive labels.
Just like it's such a nice touch.
Because I like to do semantic labeling on
GitHub and GitLab and everywhere else. And it
always looks really janky because I have, like,
colons or slashes. And and the way that
it works on Gitea, I said, oh, yeah.
What that? And that was the the secret
feature. So Oh, this Gitea, that was
contributed from the Blender Foundation, the three d
open
modeling software.
And
because
we supported them through their migration from fabricator
to Gitea.
Nice.
And so
so they contributed stuff, and we did stuff
for the project for them as well. And
so, yeah, that was
Brecht specifically
from
the Blender Foundation who contributed that as well
as
many other things as well. So we're very
thankful for
them, the community, and yeah.
Yeah. It's just those those subtle touches and
attention to detail that just make it more
pleasant. And I I like the responsiveness of
all the issues and people contributing as well.
It gives me confidence when I'm adopting something.
But, yeah. I mean, I'm not here just
to sit and sing the praises of the
project. No. I just I'll I'll just say
I was very, very happy and very impressed
when I was looking at it just literally
two months ago. So, anyway, let's get back
on track. Oh, no. Definitely.
Alright. Let's just do a quick I know
you didn't say it to hear some of
your stuff, but is there anything in the
like it's been fifteen, sixteen months, I think,
since we we did our stream together. So
what's happened in that time? And if you
wanna talk about besides actions, we will get
to Oh, definitely. Yeah. Actually, I think one
of the things that launched just after
our
last livestream was we introduced Gitea packages where
it's we're now supporting, like, 20 different types
of packages, docker images, helm charts,
Ruby gems, Rust cargo,
Python, PyPI, Alpine,
Debian devs, RPMs,
and, like,
a whole bunch more. So being able to
store your artifacts
inside the application,
and link it to your, source control and
releases if need be.
So that's very exciting, and,
that's,
definitely ties in with, actions because you can
use actions to build your Docker container and
push it just into your,
instance as well and keep it all self
contained,
have that,
data ownership, data sovereignty over your own stuff
so,
you can sure it doesn't go away.
Awesome.
Yeah.
I actually which again, it's it's I feel
like I'm just saying these things because you're
on the stream, but, honestly, I was exploding
and playing with this just, like, two months
ago.
And the package stuff is what I was
looking at because I have a a mono
repository
with, you know, dozens of services, and it's
going to be hundreds of services eventually.
They all have their own container image, and
the registry was a big part of, like,
what was interesting there as well.
But I did notice, and I have opened
an issue for this. I'm not gonna just
run at you as someone who's on my
screen. Right? But Giteapp
and GitLab also have this problem where
when you have a mono repository, the releases
always assume it's like a single artifact. And
although they can have names, it's very difficult
to browse and navigate and segment that page.
I I'd love to try and, you know,
raise the priority of that issue and fix
it live right now. We're not looking at
actions. Let's
yeah. So that's just my own little wish
list, but awesome. The package stuff is very,
very cool.
Right. Anything else besides that you wanna cover?
No.
Let's see. Yeah. Packages, actions.
We did project boards last time we were
here, I think. That was already in.
Yeah. It's great. Let's just dive right in.
Well, I'm I'm gonna ask you a slightly
Oh, sure. Controversial question, not to put you
against the water f on that. Right? But
the
the trend so far from what I see
with what we have discussed on the stream
and what I see on the project is
Gitea's
adopting and implementing a lot of things that
provide a backwards compatibility. And therefore, may be
coming from GitHub.
And as as we're gonna see with actions,
right, you you talked about how it's compatible
with that. How do you use a a
TOC
decide
when it's
better to just support people coming in versus
innovation? Like, or can you do both? Like,
I wonder how those conversations work.
Yeah. No. That's definitely something.
And in fact, with actions,
we did deviate
just ever so slightly from the GitHub standards
not to
make a breaking change,
but just to add upon it. With
GitHub actions,
it's very tied into the GitHub ecosystem.
It's user slash repo
at, git tag, and that's your actions.
But because we wanted to be able to
have actions hosted elsewhere,
we actually
introduced a a new URL,
schema for being able to define your actions
elsewhere. So instead of GitHub username, GitHub repo,
Git tag,
you can actually pass in a full URL
of a Git repo elsewhere. So if
you wanna use
an actions hosted on Gitea.com,
Gitea Com / user / repo.
And
but we keep it backwards compatible with GitHub.
So if you do have that username slash
repo
format,
it will fetch it from GitHub directly.
Awesome. Alright. I look forward to seeing that
as we explore actions as we move into
the hands on component.
What I'll say for the people watching, if
you do have any questions, please drop them
into the comment section. Matti and I would
be happy to chat about them and hopefully
get you some answers at the same time
too.
Alright, Matti. Are you ready to get a
terminal and start playing with some stuff?
Yeah.
Fingers crossed. I'm I'm sure you're confident it's
gonna work. Right? Come on.
Alright.
Where's my screen share?
Disappeared.
Oh, I'm not sharing my screen. That's the
problem. Alright.
I swear I've done this before.
Alright. And then pop back here for a
second.
I made the terrible mistake of trying to
have Microsoft Edge, and now I need to
give it the permission to share my screen.
Yeah. And sometimes you need to restart the
browser.
Yeah. Usually, I'm quite good at tracking it.
I don't wanna count my check-in as I
am. But normally,
I can just say, sure. Later. And then
do the thing anyway, and it
lets me away with it. Let's see.
No.
What
happens if I leave the stream? Shall we
find out?
Yeah.
I think because it's a YouTube,
they'll keep it open so you can
rejoin. People may need to refresh
at the worst case.
Right. Fingers crossed. I will see you in
ten seconds or quicker.
Alright. If you're in chat,
just,
make sure to say something to,
show that
we're still going.
Alright.
Alright. We're good. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That that
was that was painless. I just said, this
show is already alive. Do you wanna join?
And I was like, yes, please. I don't
wanna leave him hanging for too long. I
don't know. I'm sure you were telling some
awesome jokes. It's all good.
Alright. So
if we pop over here,
I have a terminal.
Let me reopen that tab that I had
too.
And we have the Gitea website.
So
as always on Rawkode live, we're gonna do
our best to use the documentation. That means
that anything that we do, you can follow
along at home in your own time. And
if we run any problems,
then fear not. We have someone on the
call who's gonna fix everything live for us.
No pressure, Matthew.
But
let's go. I take it we're just going
straight to documentation.
Yep. Alright.
No. I haven't looked at the action stuff
in advance, but I'll use the nice search
bar and here we go. So
I'm assuming this is gonna be relatively straightforward
because of, you know, I'm assuming that I
definitely have experience with GitHub actions. I'm assuming
that people watching this probably have some exposure
or experience there too and it should be
plain sailing. I know that's a brave word
to throw out there at the start of
the stream. Right? But what I'm curious about
now is we
could
take a project that doesn't have any sort
of pipelines and start to build stuff together.
But based on what you've told me, I'm
assuming I could take any project that has
a working pipeline just now and it should
work out the box. Right?
Mostly.
There,
it's,
that's why I say mostly GitHub actions compatible.
There are, some type of,
actions,
the composite actions in GitHub,
that aren't supported yet.
Whereas bundling of a bunch of different type
of actions into one.
But
we could start off with a blank project
and then move on to being able to
do an existing one.
Okay.
So I'll ask one question, and then I'll
I'll we'll we'll just do the, like, a
cargo new or something and get a simple
Rust project on the go. But
can I run Gitea actions locally? I know
that's one of the main frustrations, right, when
people are like, I mean, I've done this
myself. You push 14 times to the main
branch, Trist, like, I, fix I, fix I.
And it's all because we don't have that
ability just to run the damn thing locally.
Is that something that Gitea
actions has cloned, or have you fixed that?
So
so, actually so Gitea actions is based
our
engine is
a fork of a project called Nekto slash
Act,
where it was exactly that problem that trying
to solve of, like,
debugging,
updating your actions
without having to push all the time. And
one of our maintainers is actually a maintainer
over there, and there's lots of
contributions
between the two projects.
And I was actually talking with
one of the folks over at
Dager recently, and one of
the employees over at Dagger actually have
a similar project
that
I'm completely blanking on the name,
but
it's a similar thing. And I believe they're
also using it in Dagger to be able
to support,
some of their, CI stuff.
So
your pain point has been solved for GitHub
as well, but
you can do you can use the CI,
this, act runner binary to run it, your
workflows locally as well as,
it's the same binary to run your
workflows locally as on a server.
Alright. Cool. Yeah. You're right. The the tech
team do have a code name for a
project that runs those pipelines, but I can't
remember what the name of that is either.
Yeah.
I'm gonna clarify this again, and I think
we've done this on the first stream. I
keep saying Gitea, and I think you're saying
Gitea.
Am
I wrong? Is it Gitea? Or just I
say Gitea.
Other members of the team say it differently.
Pretty much everyone I talk to says it
differently. It's
I'm pretty sure you could run a livestream
where all you do is pick up random
projects and talk about the naming because everybody
seems to get this stuff wildly different. Anyway,
not that important.
Alright. So you you we're gonna create a
new project. We're gonna build a Gitea pipeline,
Mhmm. I'm just gonna do cargo new. Unless,
do you have a preferred runtime or language
that you wanna use for this demo?
Generally,
like, we do everything in Go, so
that's what I'd be most familiar with.
But for extra challenges, we could do Rust.
I just I'm not familiar with the GitHub
actions for Rust,
which is what we'd likely use.
No problem. I can do Go.
Well, I can write enough Go or remember
enough Go that I can do hello world
at least anyway. So
I'll go in.
Main dot whole. I was trying to work
it while I was against syntax highlighting. I
was like, have I forgotten go? Alright.
Oh, I have forgotten. And your package definition
as well. Oh, your package page. Thank you.
Yeah.
That's why I couldn't import. Okay. Thank you.
So let's just check. If we do go
run main, we should get hello world. Nice
and simple. Alright.
So I'm a go developer. I've ran a
million dollar program. I wanna put together some
sort of pipeline to start shipping.
Let's just say a container image.
What's what's my first step then with Giteactions?
So,
first step is,
we assume you have a Gitea instance,
set up already, and I saw that you
signed up for Gitea.com,
within the past week.
So we can push, the repos there,
and you can hook up your runner,
to your user over there as well.
Okay.
So
I believe this is just an overview, and
we can pop over to quick start. Fingers
crossed. That's where our
documentation is.
So
it's already enabled on the instance.
Here we go.
Okay. So the first thing I need to
do is just make sure I have access
to to act then.
Yeah. So there's
you can download the binary from the release
page.
There's also the docker image,
which does make it
you do need to do,
some stuff, to expose,
the Docker socket if you're running the
runner
inside of Docker for Docker and Docker.
So
the binary might be easiest
because it's just download that executable and run
it.
Alright. Well, I am gonna try something slightly
different.
Just because I've been playing have you heard
of Package X?
I haven't. No. Have you done a livestream
on that yet?
No. I I I should reach out. So
it's well, you may have heard of it
as t, but they renamed it because I
think people were getting a bit confused with
the blockchain or tea protocol stuff. And I
guess I'm sorry. It's essentially
a successor to Homebrew by the original author
of Homebrew.
Oh, exciting.
And
yeah.
I can remember what the first line of
this fail is. You just need a list
of packages.
But I can just do this
and it will give me act.
And I think it's just dependencies.
And from here,
if we run dev,
it resolves the graft.
And
now,
we have act.
Yeah.
That's pretty neat. Yeah. So that's act,
but we'll need
the act runner. So
You have to throw that in the works.
I didn't know we needed something else. That's
alright. It's
it's just a different URL, but
it's
pretty much the same.
Yeah.
The package x has something called a pantry,
and if it doesn't exist or not, it
doesn't exist. So I guess we're gonna have
to go the other route then. So Mm-mm.
That was a nice idea while it ran.
I'm just gonna go to the download page.
Let's keep it simple.
Alright.
Let's look like the latest.
And we want
Arm 64.
Mhmm.
And what I'll do is just
move it from downloads
to ActRunner,
two month plus x,
And schedule move.
What is it on that m one Mac?
Opt.
Okay. We have act and act runner. Any
other prerequisites?
I can jump back over to the docs
if there's a list.
Just
docker and the binary.
Okay. Then I think So we're good to
go. Sweet. So now we can run that
command.
Okay. So we need an instance and a
token. Right? Yeah.
Okay. So just use git2.com?
Yep.
And you can pop over to your
user settings.
And
there are scopes on
the runners,
you can either scope your runner to a
repo
to
an organization,
or if you control the instance entirely, you
can scope it to
the entire instance.
Yeah. I haven't imported any of my
things yet. So let's just create a new
repository. We'll call this go hello world
and then go. There we go.
Okay. Edit.
Get remote.
Add origin. Oh, wait. It does that. Okay.
Branch.
Main.
Add git at
and commit.
Horrible commit message. Punch it to me.
Push origin.
I'm not adding my
key.
Oh, you added, your origin as,
the HTTP
endpoints.
So
you'll have to swap your origin to the
SSH one.
Git.
Oh, okay.
Git config.
Alright. We're in business.
So now
if we come to
the repository,
We have our million dollar application.
Perfect.
So now is where we want to register
a runner, which is just going to be
a local runner on my machine. Right?
Yep.
So this instance,
is this just gitea.com?
Yeah. Htpsgitea.com.
Alright. And the token, I'm assuming I'm gonna
have to create some sort of access token.
Yeah. Okay.
And so it's, this is gonna be, exposed
to the world. It's fine, because,
they rotate, once they're used.
And, yeah, you can't see the entire of
it entirety of it right now. And once
you use it, it can't be used again.
So
Oh. There
we go. Oh, so every time you use
a registration token, it gets rotated?
Yes. Yeah. Nice. Very cool. So these are
all, one time use.
There is a capability to,
reuse them,
in if you change some settings, but by
default,
one time use only.
Awesome.
Alright. Well, looks like we we potentially have
a runner. So let's jump back to our
quick start So
we did this.
In fact, can I now oh, not visualize
it, but you know what? See it as
a registered runner? Refresh this page. You'll see
it there. Okay. Nice. So it's been registered.
And
the
next step is to start the daemon, and
that should be in the documentation as well.
Okay.
Before we do that, I'll ask you a
quick question.
This is for me to run and host
my own runners. Is there a plan for
the Gitea project to provide any sort of
shared runners, or do you just want people
to to go run their own?
Yeah. So, with, Gitea Cloud,
you can, purchase,
minutes.
But due to, like, crypto mining and such,
we can't, just offer
much for free.
Man, those crypto miners are in everything. They
jack up the prices of GPUs.
Now AI's doing that too, and now we
don't even get free build.
Alright. So let's go back
pop down. So we're gonna run this.
Damn it.
There you go. I'm not familiar with the
act project
based on only I only know what base
that you've told me at the start of
the session. I'm assuming this is just gonna
manage and run a whole bunch of containers
on my machine for each of the pipeline
steps within the the workflow file. Is that
close enough? That's exactly it. Yeah. And,
so this will, run-in the foreground.
Based on configuration, you can change it, but
for now,
run it in foreground.
There's some
documentation
on
running it with system d and other such
ways. But
Okay. Well, just talking. Split that in half,
and we're good to go.
So I'm assuming now we just write
our workflow file.
That's exactly it.
Alright.
Do you support dot GitHub just to make
the the migration for people easier, or do
you expect them to redeem the directory?
I I
believe we support dot GitHub,
but
I'm I can't remember off the top of
my head.
Alright.
See, one of my biggest complaints about GitHub
actions
again, it's just such a mono repo thing,
and I always feel like a niche person
when I talk about it. But there has
to be more people doing mono repos. Right?
But they expect all of these build definitions
to live at the root of my repository,
and I actually want my build definition to
live next to each service.
Mhmm. You know, if you wanna make it
so that I can have a dot Gitea
workflows everywhere in my repository, I'd be a
very happy person.
But not for today.
I'm just gonna copy this one just now
and we can tweak as required.
Okay.
So we we give it a name,
some sort of run name. I I don't
know. I haven't seen I haven't seen that
before. We got have actions. I don't know
what that does. We tell it to run
on push
and then it has a job. The job
has a name. We're just seeing run on
Ubuntu and then do all the things.
I'm gonna add one more job then, which
is called go build.
And this runs
on
this could be any container image. Right? So
So
what it does is
the runs on
is,
like, a label for the runner itself.
Oh, okay. And as in chat that just
popped up, it's actually not Ubuntu.
We're by default, the act project
defines
the default image to be
the node
18 Docker image,
which is based on Debian.
So
using
Ubuntu is a bit of a misnomer.
And in
GitHub actions, I believe it's
the runs on wouldn't be where you put
the image. It's in the container
key,
I believe.
Right. Okay. Yeah. So this would be a
runs on where we then add steps. So
this is where we'd have go
blah blah blah. Yeah. Setup action slash setup
go.
And we need to check out, actually. So
let's just copy that from
here.
Go. And then
we'd have a container with everything we need,
and we could just say go run
main dot go. That seem okay? Yep.
Alright.
So
I'm assuming I'm just pushing this because we
have
a runner running, which is registered with gitea.com.
So provided
we do a
commit
feature
new CI system.
Awesome.
We
can do a push.
Let's pop back over here.
And if we
go to Rawkode,
We have one action.
Hey.
Hey. It's running. Nice.
Well, if they pop to my machine yeah.
We're starting to alright. There we go. There's
all the log outputs from our new CI.
And go build. Oh, we got a fail
on the go build. Oh,
I'm gonna see what happened.
Input string was not in the correct format.
Action setup go. Did I need a version?
Oh, yeah. Possibly.
I
think it's v four might be the latest
because
GitHub actions recently
bumped everything to
use node 20 as their base.
And so
that's the difference between v three and v
four.
Well, nobody's build passes the first time.
I'll give that just a moment.
That was pretty fast, that first one there.
Mean, I know it's only doing echoes, but
five seconds was was bad.
And I guess so why pulled the images
there. Right? It's cached locally.
Yeah. So we'll cache, the actions locally.
Yeah.
I guess you need to define
a specific version.
Five.
Oh,
no. Before.
Oh, okay. It might require that. Yeah. Okay.
Is that what you were just saying that
I wasn't listening?
That might be
yeah. That might require it.
With
go
one twenty one.
Okay. So, I mean, we are already doing
that thing that I said I hate. Right?
Like, fix the eye. Yeah. Yeah. Can I
test this locally first?
Yeah. Yeah. So
so because you have the act runner
binary locally, you can run act underscore runner
space exec,
and it will
and you just enter,
and then
it's running it right now.
So it's fetching the go binary in the
setup go step right now.
It fetched it.
And if you scroll up at
sec Okay. There should be the hello world.
Yep.
Alright. So let's
break it
because I had it broken, so I'm gonna
say broken.
Alright. Perfect. K.
Nice.
And we'll fix that back up. And random
question, but it's something I I I use
a lot is the
be able to click the button to execute
it on the UI. I can't remember what
it's called, but it's push or it's like
something else. Can I can I do that?
Yeah. On
workflow, I believe,
that's not
supported yet.
There's a Yeah. On dispatch or something. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. There's a
a pull request in progress for that right
now.
Awesome.
But we
recently
launched
so
in addition to
going fully stable
with this latest major release, we also, support
scheduled
actions, so Cron as well. So that was,
one of the compatibility things with GitHub actions
that we, added as well.
Alright. Very cool. So I could just set
up a a cron run to run every
night at 3AM or whatever
and push out images.
And with same with GitHub actions you can
do on pull request. So
it will only run on a pull request
or
push to a specific branch
on tags. So if you take something,
you'd have a Go release or go
build your project and actually
upload the artifacts wherever you wish.
Alright.
Nice.
I mean, it's it seems to be the,
you know, the quick demo we've done pretty
much on a par with what we would
expect from GitHub actions.
And how far into the
Gitea subsystem does this go? And by that,
I mean, like, you know, if I do
have external contributors and pull requests
and I wanna have, like, blocking merge until
passing,
is this something in motion? Is this something
that already exists? Like, where are we with
with that kind of migration?
Yeah. So Gitea
already has, like, branch protection for pull requests,
so ensure that, like, certain statuses pass.
And
that's for external
integrations,
external CI,
or, like, if you're
if you have, like, Jira or something you
need to hook up,
like,
some sign up in Jira and send over
webhook somewhere, you can do that.
But then
in the branch protection as well,
GitHub actions come in as statuses
as well. So you can say
it requires
these specific statuses to pass before you can
even click the merge button.
And that would be under, branch protection. Yeah.
And you can white list who,
is able to merge,
based on, like, a team or a
user group,
or a specific user,
the number of,
approvals.
So not just, status checks,
but also, like, number of approvals from a
specific team. So
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Very nice.
Yeah. Yeah.
Alright.
So I'm liking what I'm seeing.
It's very familiar.
The Ubuntu is not Ubuntu. That's me that's
gonna be the one takeaway thing that I
remember for the next twelve months. Like, when
you get back to me and say, I
remember that stream of it. I remember Ubuntu
is not Ubuntu. Yeah.
So you can actually change it to the
Ubuntu image if you wish. We skipped a
few steps when
registering,
your runner.
If you go
if you scroll back in your terminal,
you'll see that it says,
it registered with a certain
labels
of
Ubuntu latest, Ubuntu 20, Ubuntu 18, I believe.
Where are we?
And here we go. Yeah. So
I'm running with
the certain labels
a couple lines down from where your cursor
is right now
under act run daemon at the top there,
the longest line.
There
we go. Yep. Up.
Yeah. So running
You'll see the several labels
defined above, and then
those actually do alias to that specific Docker
image.
But you can also
you don't need to run inside of a
Docker.
You'd not necessarily use this for if you're
accepting, like, open contributions because
then,
people can run, code as the
runner on whichever machine you use.
Right now, that's the only way to run,
like, if you're building an iOS application
or whatnot. If you wanna run,
like, Xcode, compile, and stuff,
you would have to have, the host mode,
so it wouldn't be isolated inside of a
container,
so people could potentially browse your
file system.
But again,
that's not for, untrusted environments.
Yeah.
And you can change, the labels you want.
You can change the default images.
So
yeah.
And
in fact, for the Gitea project,
we actually use,
one of the act contributors,
has built an image,
a docker image that's quite hefty,
but it's
very comparable to the virtual machine that GitHub
runners have access to. So all of the
tools
that are installed there,
would be available to you because
this docker image doesn't have things like j
q.
It's it's literally just the node docker image.
So and that's one of the ways that
existing actions might fail is they might assume
that a tool is available,
that isn't necessarily available in the image that
you're running with.
Alright. Nice.
Is there anything else from the action stuff
that we haven't covered yet that you want
me to to go peek into?
No. I think that was a great example
of,
I think, showing pulling an image,
like, I use as
action slash setup go. That's pulling from github.com.
And
yeah. What's the the syntax if we were
gonna use
the new thing. Right? Yeah. So it'd be
instead of
just actions slash checkout, it'd be htpscolon//yeety.com/actions,
/checkout,
and then add v three.
Yeah.
And, this works because,
we have the code mirrored,
from Giteap.com.
So if you're pulling from,
giteap.com
for this specific action,
it's what you'd expect.
Does this work for any arbitrary, like, Gitea
instance?
Yeah. So if you wanna
Like,
code.Rawkode.academy,
like, something like that, that Yeah. That would
just work out the box. Right?
It works out of the box with a
little asterisk
of
you potentially may need
to set up authentication
if it's, a private repository or whatnot.
GitHub actions oh, sorry. Gitea actions handles a
lot of that out of the box. When
you're cloning, it creates a temporary access,
key to be able to pull the repository.
But for, like, actions, you also need to
define saying, hey. This is a protected repository.
You'll need to, like, be aware of that.
Alright. Cool. Yeah. That's a cool little feature,
especially as we
try and encourage people, right, to have their
Git hosting a little bit more decentralized than
that than it is at the moment.
I like that approach.
Alright.
Let me pop this back over. We can
go always go back to the demo if
we think of something else that we wanna
show there, but I wanna kinda chat about
what was covered already. Yeah. Definitely. And so
I think the the familiarity aspect of it,
the fact that people don't really need to
change anything when they're coming from GitHub is
just
that that's the way it probably should be.
Right? You wanna make it the path of
least resistance, otherwise, developers are lazy. We're not
gonna do that. And I like that. But
you're also not unwilling to make changes, like
with the URL construct, which is also very
cool. I hope that more stuff kind of
comes along there. I like that the an
act maintainer is also working on this. That
means that that support is only gonna get
better, especially when it comes to debugging actions
and stuff like that. I think that's gonna
provide paramount
better developer experience than what we have today.
And this is all very, very exciting.
But you are on the TOC. You're close
to oh. Oh. Damn it.
Computer hits me.
Alright. I'm just gonna talk for a second,
and then I'll fix this. That's quite alright.
You're on the you're on the the TOC,
and you're close to the project. So why
don't you tell me what's coming on next?
What you just wanna change? What's what are
people asking for? What is the future of
Giteactions?
Yeah. Definitely.
Well,
the short term road map is increase that
compatibility
with GitHub actions that
the on workflow
dispatch step that you brought up,
the
composite action support. So
they're not widely used,
but they're used enough that
it should be supported
as well as creating different types of runners.
So right now, there's the two modes. There's
the running in Docker container or running in
host mode.
But
as we've seen from, like, other projects
of,
CRCI,
they have their
Tarte dot dev project where you can actually
run, like,
macOS virtual machines,
as, like, Docker containers kind of somewhat,
being able to just support,
various different back ends.
So, like, ephemeral Windows images as well for
your Windows developers,
building those, dot net projects,
iOS devs,
and
and just bringing the project forward that way.
And
yeah.
Alright. And what about the
Gitea project beyond actions? Like, do you have
a a road map of other new things
that are gonna be coming to this table
and
Yeah. So
this upcoming release, we're working on,
like,
stability
and
so it's not a big feature release sales.
It's just a lot of, refactoring. There's there's
plenty of, features coming in.
We're at a few hundred,
pull requests,
already for it, so it's not in insignificant.
But that's
always with
every big thing you need to go back,
ensure stability of the project, as well as
we're working forward
towards a long term support version. So
understanding that not everyone is able to,
upgrade to the latest and greatest,
but still,
need to have those bug fixes, security fixes
as well
and
just create that,
reliable and understandable,
upgrade cadence.
So
they stay on an LTS for a year.
They're able to keep those small updates.
And then if
then in their upgrade cycle, if they're able
to, like, evaluate, like, potential breaking changes,
then they can do that with going to,
like, the next version and whatnot.
Alright. Kind of tangential then or adjacent to
what we're talking about, not really directly, but,
you know, I'm curious if you see people,
matter in like, you said you matter all
of the Giteaub action stuff, right, to the
gitea.com?
We sorry. A lot of it, not A
lot of it. Yeah. Yeah. I should be
careful with my wording there for sure.
Do you see people doing that for a
redundancy thing as well? Like, just pulling in
their vendor dependencies from Yeah. GitHub. I mean,
let's face it. GitHub and GitLab. There's been
a lot of downtime.
Entirely.
So,
actually,
on my NASA home, I have my own
instance, and it's mirroring a few thousand
repositories
because, like,
just like if my Internet goes down, if
GitHub goes down, GitLab goes down, what have
you, it's all there. Or repository is deleted,
you'll you'll have the famous left pad instance
or incident.
Yep. And so
even though, like, with,
like, Go modules,
Google has their
package
mirror.
It's available.
So if things do go away, it's still
kind of available,
but, that cash is purged,
on whatever,
basis.
So it's just,
having a copy of your code is integral,
especially if you're in an enterprise
building,
like, whatever project and,
like, just having a copy for insurance sake
is, incredibly important.
Awesome.
Alright.
Is there anything else you wanna cover before
we wrap this thing up?
No.
I think yeah. No.
It's no big
showstoppers with Gitea action setting up, which is
always exciting, same
as
our last livestream, living up to that
painless
tagline.
And
yeah. No. Thanks again for
having me on. It was great to see
you again. And
yeah. Awesome. Thanks. Alright. Well, couple of things,
and then we'll say goodbye. One, your green
screen setup is awesome. Like, Thanks. Very little
artifacts
around your your face and shoulders. I'm really
impressed. Mhmm. I'm gonna ask you about that
later.
And the second one is just, like, Gitea
is such a cruel project. You know, there's
a lot of things we take for granted
as developers and operators,
you know, access to GitHub.com and and GitLab
and stuff like that. But there needs to
be a better decentralized
model moving forward. I think it's gonna be
so important. And the fact, you know, Gitea,
it's it's not shiny and exciting. It's essential.
It's plumbing. It's what it's foundational, right, to
what we need for our developer teams and
and organizations. So, you know, thank you to
you and everyone else working on the Gitea
project, all the contributors.
It's always exciting to see the updates, and
thank you for taking time to join me
today. No. Of course. Thank you for having
me.
Alright.
Thank you all for watching. Have a wonderful
day. We'll be back again on Friday with
another episode of Rawkode Live. Matthew, thank you
again. I'll speak to you soon. And everyone,
have a great day. Thanks. Bye.